das tagesgespräch bei phoenix heute mit
ulrich lilie den präsidenten der
diakonie ich grüße sie ganz herzlich ja
gut norden bevor wir gleich mal über
impfpflicht auch bei pflegepersonal
reden erst einmal zur situation in den
krankenhäusern und in den
pflegeeinrichtungen wie sieht es aktuell
aus die situation ist dramatisch
und wir wissen ja jetzt schon dass wir
jetzt die fakten haben die uns in drei
oder vier wochen gravierend beschäftigen
werden alle fachleute haben das vorher
gesagt nun haben wir eine sehr sehr sehr
komplizierte situation die viele viele
tote kosten wird und in viele menschen
sehr sehr gesundheitlich beeinträchtigen
wird daran müssen wir jetzt alles tun um
diesen rasen den zug zu stoppen wo
stellen wir dann in drei bis vier wochen
also kurz vor weihnachten
ich glaube dass wir dann die folgen
haben dessen was wir gerade an bildern
in köln gesehen haben dass wir dann
einfach hochgerechnet die situation
haben dass viele intensivstationen
übervoll geworden sind dass wir menschen
verlegen müssen wir müssen jetzt alles
tun um vor allen dingen pflegeheime
einrichtungen der behindertenhilfe zu
sicheren orten zu machen das heißt wir
müssen jetzt sehr schnell zusammen mit
der bundeswehr es hinbekommen dass wir
der stationen haben dass da keiner rein
kommt er nicht getestet ist wir müssen
jetzt unbedingt die impfungen
weitertragen und wir müssten boostern
wust an ostern das heißt wir müssen
jetzt sehr viele dinge gleichzeitig tun
und nicht nur auf ein pferd setzen dann
reden wir auch über die impfungen also
das testen aus dass eine impfung das
andere im scherz dabei dem pflegen denn
aus ja ich glaub wir sollten nicht nur
über die pflegen den reden die
pflegenden machen im moment ja wirklich
ein ein job zum niederknien und wir
können gar nicht dankbar genug sein
diesen menschen die da wirklich alles
geben wir müssen auf alle berufsgruppen
gucken die mit menschen zu tun haben die
verletzlich sind das heißt in den
altenpflegeeinrichtungen aber genauso in
den einrichtungen der behindertenhilfe
ich denke wir müssen auch über
kindertagesstätten sprechen hier werden
die
übertragungsraten eben dringend zu
unterbrechen sein und darum müssen wir
hier über eine pflicht reden ich habe
das vor einigen wochen schon angekündigt
der ethikrat hat es gesagt alle
pflegeverbände sagen es inzwischen wir
müssen jetzt handeln und wir müssen
schneller werden mit dem handeln und wir
müssen gucken dass wir wieder vor die
lage kommen und manchmal aus wort zu
bringen sie sind für eine impfpflicht
richtig ich bin für eine impfpflicht für
alle menschen die in diesen
einrichtungen arbeiten das heißt sowohl
für die menschen die für die raumpflege
verantwortlich sind wie für die
köchinnen und köche und natürlich dann
auch für die pflegenden es geht aber um
alle berufsgruppen die eben in diesen
einrichtungen ein und aus gehen damit
wir jetzt sichere orte schaffen und
nicht die todeszahlen wirklich wieder
auf eine fatale art und weise in die
höhe schnellen wir sind schon viel zu
spät und wir müssen jetzt schnell viele
maßnahmen gemeinsam machen das heißt wir
müssen impfen wir müssen testen und wir
müssen boostern sich kennen aber auch
die diskussionen der impfgegner und
derer die sagen impfpflicht geht
eigentlich gar nicht ja ich glaube wir
müssen jetzt auch mal darüber reden was
impfpflicht heiß im pflicht heißt ja
nicht dass die leute mit dem
polizeiwagen zum arzt gefahren werden
sondern das heißt dass es jetzt
verpflichtend ist dass man ein
ordnungsgeld hat und dass wir aufhören
vielleicht auch die ein oder andere sehr
moralisierende diskussion zu führen wir
haben nun wirklich evidenzen wir haben
zahlen wir sollten eine rationale
diskussion führen ich halte manches
gespenst dass der in richtung spaltung
erzählt wird wirklich auch für ein
warmes wort wir müssen jetzt handeln
denn wenn wir nicht einfach sehenden
auges in kauf nehmen wollen dass
debatten geführt werden werden jeden tag
ein flugzeug abstürzt mit menschen die
das mit ihrem leben bezahlen ist so eine
frage von vorbild in diesem fall aber
auch eine frage von fürsorge wenn dann
aber trotzdem noch personal da ist dass
ich nicht impfen lassen will was
passiert mit denen dann muss man sagen
ihr müsst dann einfach in einer in einer
art und weise arbeiten die nicht
patienten da ist nicht bewohnbar ist
und dann muss man auch sagen es gibt
eine verpflichtung es gibt eine
verpflichtung wenn ich mit sehr
verletzlichen menschen arbeite dass ich
von berufswegen alles dafür tun dass
diese menschen geschützt werden das ist
nicht nur eine frage von freiheit und
selbstbestimmung sollen das ist auch
eine frage von gerechtigkeit
und folgenabschätzung und für die folgen
habe ich dann eben auch eine
verantwortung wenn ich in diesem
handlungsfeld arbeite es ist ja auch so
dass ich belegschaften angestellte
arbeitende pflegende selber infizieren
können und auch noch krank werden und
ausfallen wie ist denn momentan der
situation überhaupt von dem personal
stärken
also haben sie sprechen ganz wichtigen
punkt an es geht natürlich auch um den
schutz der mitarbeitenden untereinander
dem dass die sich nicht anstecken weil
dann haben wir auch eine gravierende
situation und wir hatten ja in den
letzten monaten eben auch damit zu tun
dass viele an der erschöpfungs grenze
waren und manche sich auch angesteckt
haben und zwar eine ganz große anzahl
das wird jetzt zu beobachten sein wie
sich das weiterentwickelt genaue zahlen
haben wir da im moment nicht aber wir
müssen jetzt eben präventiv handeln wir
müssen jetzt sozusagen
vorhersehen das was in sechs acht wochen
ist anfangen zu steuern denn sonst wird
auch der januar und der februar
furchtbar und zwar mit ansage das können
wir uns jetzt nicht mehr leisten
vielleicht zwei wochen drei wochen vier
wochen wissen es nicht genau werden wir
eine neue regierung haben was schreiben
sie der neuen regierung ins
hausaufgabenheft
dass wir jetzt sofort eine task force
einrichten wo der gesundheitsminister
die gesundheitsministerin innenminister
innenministerin hochrangige leute auch
aus der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz im
zusammen sind mit den fachleuten die ja
gerade briefe geschrieben haben weil sie
sagen wir sind fassungslos darüber dass
alles das was wir vorhergesagt haben
nicht gesehen wird und dass wir dann
wirklich eine präventive politik machen
die vorausschauend sicherheiten schafft
und nicht hinterher läuft das müssen wir
jetzt hinbekommen und das muss diese
neue koalition nun schaffen sagt ulrich
lilie der präsident der diakonie ich
sage hat sich danke schön für das
gespräch einen schönen tag